on termine avec le festival du film
américain à deauville cette semaine une
manifestation devenue traditionnelle et
qui permet chaque année de voir les
stars du cinéma américain déambuler sur
les fameuses planches
le reportage de nicole cornu langlois et
dominique merlet adoumim
j'aide crazy désopilant hellzapoppin du
rock est l'un des 35 films présentés en
avant première au festival de deauville
devenu rampe de lancement du cinéma
américain qu'il s'agisse de
superproductions ou de films
indépendants
c'est aussi un lieu de rencontre
présidée par anne d'ornano qui reçoit
cinéaste français et star hollywoodienne
venu pour des hommages en forme de
rétrospective ou de conférences comme
celle que dungeon fontaine la pure
héroïne hitchcockienne de soupçons et de
rebecca qui évoque son réalisateur
préféré minima tandis que henry hathaway
un monument hollywoodien fait un constat
sur un demi siècle consacré au cinéma
one cardiaque
allez hop
mais la véritable vedette de ce festival
c'est un enfant franco-américain de 11
ans sébastien dunkan héros de un homme
une femme un enfant un petit garçon très
triste parce qu'il a juste perdu sa mère
l'a jamais connu son père etc ans quand
sa mère est morte il est complètement
dans le désespoir il n'y a pas de
familles là rien et
et un jour par en amérique pour voir des
amis de sa mère
mais le début il fallait vraiment que je
m'exerce et je m'efforce de faire bien
et c'est drôle mijo vrac cessé de rire
qui était plus difficile
parce que de pleurer si ça m'a paru
beaucoup plus facile de rire c'était
difficile et le soir le tout cinéma
danse sur la musique de flash dance
comédie musicale aérobic dynamique et
tonique de adrian line en piste j'espère
que le film profite de deux vidéos de
des images hot vidéo surtout pas aux
victimes et il ya une chaîne qui face à
laquelle et aux états unis qui s'appelle
m6 vie et tous les toutous les gosses
regarde ça et je crois que de
redressement
les enfants sont beaucoup plus
sophistiqué visuellement qu'avant
et regardez bien ce n'est pas l'actrice
jennifer beals qui évolue mais une
danseuse française et c'était une fille
à marignane qui en effet qui a fait le
tout par des danses